this is the new dreambot x30 Ultra Robot
vacuum from a sponsor dream Tech and if
you guys remember our review of the l20
ultra where I called it the best robot
vacuum ever made well the x30 ultra goes
even further with brand new features
that works shockingly well making this
the new best robovac out there hands
down no competition so in this video I'm
going to explain why it's the best by
going through the main five features
their mop extend technology 2.0 which is
my favorite part the self-cleaning base
station which works with 60° C hot water
the very impressive 8300 pasas of vormax
suction fully auto robot care with auto
dust emptying and the x30 ultra
impressive smart cleaning strategy
features but first let me quickly walk
you through the unboxing and setup
starting with the robovac itself you'll
see a very familiar design with a nice
black matte finish jam-packed with
sensors in multiple spots including
lighter on the top a camera in the front
and dedicated spotlights which
automatically turn on when it's very
dark on the back you'll see two metal
pads for charging more sensors in a port
that fills the internal water tank at
the base station as well as a side port
which utilizes the auto empty dust bin
feature it's got bumpers all around the
front buttons on top and you can lift
the cover to take out the dust bin clean
the filter and see everything that's on
the inside flipping the robo back over
you can see the slots for the mop pads
as well as the rubber brush which you
can easily take out to clean heading
over to the base station you'll find all
the accessories including the spinning
brush which is very easy to pop onto the
front of the robovac the cleaning brush
with a built-in hair cutting tool and
the two mop pads that magnetically
connect to the robo vac in order to
enable a really cool feature that I'll
get into in just a minute onto the base
station itself I really love how you can
wrap up the power power cord on the back
so that it doesn't stick out when you
put it up against the wall which is
really nice and on the inside of the
station you'll find a bunch of tech
including the charging pads drains for
the water ports for automatic dust
removal and the introduction of two
built-in scrapers which keeps the base
station itself clean with hot water
opening up the lid on the top you'll
find two water tanks one for dirty water
and one for clean so before you begin
just fill it up from the sink and put it
into place now this little cover pops up
to reveal the dust bag as well as a
dedicated water tank which you'll fill
up with a mixture of water and the
included cleaning solution which will
automatically mix with the main water
when cleaning the mops so there you go
everything is now set up and ready and
the last thing you'll need to do is
download The Dream Home app and connect
the robo vac when you first open the app
it'll walk you through a bunch of
prompts so you can let it know if you
have pets at home so it's more careful
with obstacle avoidance and you can turn
on the hot water washing mode which I of
course did for better mopping
performance I turned on auto rewashing
mode which will wash the mops again if
it detects that the water is too dirty
with its builtin color sensor there's
also Auto recleaning that will clean a
dirty area twice if it detects that it's
very dirty and finally there is Aid
driven mop extend which is my favorite
feature of all because the x30 ultra
comes with a robotic Flex arm that
swings the right mop pad out
intelligently using Advanced Edge
detection so you can see how closely it
hugs corners and walls even being able
to reach as far as 4 cm into gaps and
under Furniture now this feature is
absolutely incredible because it
literally is able to get under Furniture
like my couch by swinging out the arm
getting underneath gaps like this it is
absolutely incredible there are a bunch
of settings to customize this feature in
the app including setting it to high
frequency mode but even in the default
intelligence mode it was really
surprising to see how the spinning mop
pads clean areas that wouldn't be
possible with any other Robot vacuum
including around chair legs and more
then there's the self-cleaning base
station which is the first to include
two built-in scrapers on the inside to
really clean the mops well by cleaning
them twice with 60° C water and it also
cleans the actual base station plates at
the same time so you don't have to take
them out and clean them manually and you
can actually see the process of the mobs
being cleaned from a lower angle with it
even showing up on the map in real time
when they're being washed and finally
when cleaning is done it automatically
turns on the drying cycle to dry the
mops with hot air so bacteria and mildew
don't grow and make them smell so it's
an awesome self-cleaning system the
third great feature is the 8,300 PA of
Vmax suction power which is the highest
suction in the industry being so
powerful it can hold 5 kg of weight
effectively cleaning various particles
and debris in your home for example I
sprinkled a bunch of rice krispy cereal
on the carpet and it picked up all of it
on the first pass which was honestly
really impressive because other vacs
that I've tried always leave behind some
crumps I also had to pick up a bunch of
paper scraps with no problems at all and
I spread out a bunch of coffee GR on the
floor and once again it picked them up
and cleaned them on the first pass so
the suction power and mopping is better
than I expected I even poured milk on my
floor to see how the spinning mops would
handle it and just like that it cleaned
it up on the first pass which was super
impressive and in general the mopping
performance was great where you can see
just how wet and shiny the floors become
mopping so much better than the robox
that simply have a pad that slides over
the surface instead of actual spinning
mops next up we have full auto robot
care which includes the auto mop and
base station cleaning and drying as well
as the water Port which automatically
refills the water inside of the robo vac
itself that helps keep the mop pads
saturated with water as it drives around
and it also has the automatic cleaning
solution mixing feature to be able to
really clean and freshen up your floors
and finally there's the auto empty
feature which lets you have up to 75
days of handsfree emptying by
automatically vacuuming the dust from
the internal robac into the base
station's 3.2 L dust bag which is
actually really easy to remove and
replace by pulling on the clip and
finally for feature number five we have
the smart cleaning strategy the first
time you clean the x30 ultra is going to
have you do a quick mapping scan which
has a robovac detach the mop pads and
leave them out at the base station which
is super cool and then it drives around
your house automatically sinking and
populating a full detailed map of your
house into the app using its Pathfinder
smart navigation lar and sensors it even
has the AI action and 3D obstacle
avoidance feature which was able to
identify our floor lamp in the corner
which is one of the 70 plus objects it
can identify like shoes cables and much
more and as soon as the mopping was
finished I was able to go in and
customize my cleaning settings by
increasing the suction and wetness of
the mobs before I noticed that the AI
algorithm feature was able to
intelligently split my house into three
different sections as a smart cleaning
plan including detecting my carpeted rug
and yes it actually works because when I
started cleaning it went straight to my
rug and lifted the mop pads by 10.5 mm
to avoid getting them wet and then it
vacuumed the entire rug using carpet
suction boost that instantly kicks up
the suction power when it detects carpet
and within the carpet settings you can
even set it to detach the mobs and leave
them at the base station if you'd like
or carpet avoidance which will not clean
the carpets until the very end and you
can even enable carpet intensive
cleaning which performs two passes at
lower suction to ensure a thorough
cleaning and before I wrap up this video
I want to mention that there are a ton
of extra settings you can customize like
washing options drying time how often it
empties the dust bin floor cleaning
settings scheduling to clean on a
regular basis and even being able to
access the real time camera to check up
on your home so with that said I fully
believe that this is hands down the best
robot vacuum that you can get right now
basically giving you the most hands-free
automatic cleaning possible especially
with all of the new features that
they've added so hopefully you enjoy
this video and if you did go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe for
more videos like this one thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video